All of these Exception types we've seen are part of an Exception Hierarchy. They
inherit from the Exception class. The Standard Error type is a sub-class of
Exception. And they're many different sub-classes of Standard Error, including
the Assertion Error. This is the one that gets raised when an Assertion fails.
The Environment Error, and this gets raised when something in the execution
environment is not as we expect. An example of an Environment Error, is the IO
Error that we saw when we couldn't read a file. An IO Error is a subtype of
Environment Error which is a subtype of Standard Error which is a subtype of
Exception. This is why when we have Exception It handles an IO Error, as well as
an Assertion Error. Another type of Error would be a Lookup Error. This happens
when something we're looking for doesn't exist. And there are two kinds of
Lookup Errors. An Index Error that happens when we access outside the bounds of
a list, for example. And a Key Error that happens when we look for a key that
doesn't exist in the dictionary.